what's the secret of a happy life Wow a
study by the National Center for Social
Research found that a good night's sleep
tops the list feeling well rested is
much more important than a pay rise the
researchers say a secure job and strong
family relationships are also important
to content well live tonight well I'm
joined now by the man who led to that
research in Mohan who's the director of
consulting and Oxford Economics and the
man who paid for it
Sainsbury's chief executive Mike coop
saying pay rise is really less
preferable than a good night's sleep
really well this is what our responses
to our survey and our analysis shows
rich people not at all we spoke to a
full spectrum of people in the country I
think there's something important to
remember though that's the that's that
we find that you know having when pay is
low and when people are in debt that has
a very negative effect on people's
well-being once people have a certain
amount it takes a lot to really boost
happiness money matters but just not as
much as lots of other things and job
security you always put quite a high
value on as well do you think that's
just because it's not at the forefront
of people's minds right now it could be
it could be I mean we have some people
in there who are very securing their
jobs and they consistently show much
higher levels of living well essentially
so but if you if you're on that kind of
like less secure jobs it has a serious
impact and you're close to being you
know if you're unemployed that has a
really negative impact so Mike you're
going to use this information to inform
decisions on how you run the business
how's that gonna map out what sort of
things do you have in mind well three
broad constituencies first of all of
course the people that work in our
business and understanding a little bit
more about how we might be able to help
them live their lives better is one
thing that we would be looking at and
would take the information the data from
the survey to help us do that secondly
of course our customers and again
understanding and having more insight
into what makes our customers tick is a
great thing for a supermarket chain to
be able to do it's a game of inches so
every bit of insight that you have above
and beyond your competition is is
helpful and perhaps the third thing is
to contribute to a sort of broader
national narrative because you know sort
of austerity brexit Britain it does feel
that there are great things in life that
sometimes get overlooked and I think the
survey shows that quite a lot of the
small things in life are actually things
which are very important to people so
does that mean
Sainsbury's is going to give all its
stuff pay rises then to make them feel
happier well we've already given our
staff a pretty significant pay rise this
year a four point four percent pay rise
on top of a four percent pay rise the
previous year so we're well above the
national living wage than national
minimum wage as it currently is but as
the survey says and I experienced day to
day in our shops our colleagues quite
often are the pillars of the communities
that they serve or that we serve they
have things going on outside their
working life and working in a
supermarket chain allows them to have
the flexibility to do those things so
actually when I speak to our colleagues
they they rarely talk about pay they
talk about other things in their life
but you're not miracle workers how can
you guarantee that the country is going
to sleep better at night that's one
thing I can't guarantee but of course
having the insights at least gives you
some potential opportunities to perhaps
help now one of the things we'll be
doing over the next period of time is
understanding exactly what we might be
able to do with the data the other thing
that's worth thinking about is well this
will be a continuous survey so we can
see changes over time good stuff or I
might cope and in Mohan thanks very much
for joining me both good to see you and